-The U.S. coronavirus outbreak
reached a grim new milestone
yesterday with over 3,000 deaths
in one day, a global record,
but the President was too busy
live-tweeting Fox News
and trying to get the results
of an election
he lost, overturned.
For more on this, it's time
for A Closer Look.
Every day it gets harder
and harder to articulate
just how shocking
and devastating and unbearable
this situation is and how sick
and depraved and sadistic
our leaders are.
At some point, you just
run out of words.
If, when this whole thing
started, you'd invested in
Purell, Lysol,
and thesaurus.com,
you would've made a fortune.
A king's ransom,
a tidy nest egg, racks on racks.
Sadly, I put all my stock
in rhymezone.com
and it turns out even during
quarantine no one wants
my one-man Hanukkah-themed
parody of "Jersey Boys,"
Jersey Goys.
♪ Menorah lights ♪
♪ We got a dreidel
instead of a tree ♪
♪ Ain't no prize
instead they're all for me ♪
♪ Oh, I love menorah lights ♪
In my friend group,
I've always been the Miranda,
but I guess I'm not
Lin-Manuel Miranda.
Hey, guys.
Camera operators, don't just
slip jokes in, okay?
I mean, I appreciate it,
but don't.
Anyway, the point is,
we're in the midst
of a national calamity,
unlike anything most of us has
seen in our lifetimes.
It's an ongoing emergency with
over 200,000 new cases every day
and 100,000 Americans in
the hospital as we speak.
Republicans spent over
$7 million in 2 1/2 years,
investigating four American
deaths in Benghazi in order to,
by own admission, drag down
Hillary Clinton's poll numbers.
But when you bring up COVID,
they act like it's a new
TikTok trend
they have never heard of before.
Is that the one where you eat
cereal out
of someone else's mouth?
And as grotesque and sociopathic
is the indifference
and incompetence from
the Trump administration
and Republican party have been,
there's also plenty of blame
to go around
from confusing decisions
by local officials
to close playgrounds
but keep gyms and bars open,
to hypocrites like the mayor of
Austin who told
people to stay home
while he was on vacation
in Cabo.
I mean, I'm sure it's
a wonderful place,
but just being in Cabo
sounds like
an admission of guilt.
If somebody started
a sentence,
let me explain, I was in Cabo,
you would just say shut up.
Unless of course you were
in Cancun in which case,
you know,
you'd have to hear them out.
The response to the coronavirus
has been a total failure of
American governance
from the top down and leadership
is desperately needed.
The President and his aides
could be on TV every day asking
people to stay home
for their own sake
and for the health of
their friends,
family, and fellow Americans,
they could be leading
the charge
to get direct payments to
Americans and small businesses
to help them through
the crisis, instead,
Mitch McConnell has been
holding up an aid package
in order to get a liability
shield for corporations
that put workers in harm's way,
while the White House proposed
lowering the Federal
unemployment benefit
a situation that has clearly
infuriated Vermont Senator,
Bernie Sanders.
-Unemployment, a high.
We have a record level of hunger
in America.
Millions of people
are facing evictions.
This is an emergency.
Congress has to respond
aggressively
to help working families.
You know, Stephanie,
I always get a kick.
Here in Washington where
we go to war,
there's endless
amounts of money,
tax breaks for billionaires,
endless amounts of money.
Corporate welfare,
When children are going hungry
in America today,
suddenly,
we don't have enough money.
That's crap, that's wrong.
-Can Bernie be
the new host of "Jeopardy"?
That would be fantastic.
-What is Los Angeles?
That's crap. That's wrong.
Bernie's right, and there's
no better way to say it.
The situation should be just as
outrageous to you as seeing
a BMW parked in a fire lane
or getting skipped in line
at the deli.
And you do not want to skip
Bernie at the deli.
Whoa, whoa, whoa,
excuse me.
I have number seven.
I've been waiting here
impatiently for 20 minutes
and you just serve him because
he walks up to the counter
like he owns the place.
That's wrong, that's crap.
Now I got to go, I got tickets
to Jersey Goys.
Sanders and many other
progressives
like Congressman Katie Porter
want direct payments
to Americans and in an interview
last week,
Porter took issue with the fact
that such payments
are often referred
to as stimulus.
-One of the things that's
making me really frustrated
right now is when I hear people
talk about this as stimulus.
Let's be clear.
It is not stimulus money
to give people money
so they can feed themselves.
So, that they can keep heat on
in the winter.
So that they can avoid eviction.
That's not stimulus,
that is basic needs
that we're talking about meeting
and you are absolutely right,
that it's not enough to just do
some unemployment,
it's not enough to
do more with food assistance,
people need that
direct assistance.
And she is right, too.
All that was missing was
a "that's crap,"
or, you know,
a few other swears.
Next time she should feel free
to say one of the many things
that makes me really upset at
these [bleep] gibrones is
when I hear their bitch mouths
talk about a stimulus.
It's not stimulus, it's money
for people to eat and pay for
housing and utilities.
Things Mitch McConnell doesn't
have to worry about
because according to the Center
for Responsive Politics
he has a net worth of over
$34 million,
money I assume he made
doing narration
for Kentucky ghost stories.
Gather around children,
for the tale of the coal zombie.
Porter's right that we shouldn't
call this stimulus,
it's not about stimulating
the economy,
it's about keeping people alive.
If you see someone on the side
of the road next to a car wreck,
you don't pull over and say, oh,
so you want me to call AAA?
What's next? A tourniquet
for your leg?
Everybody wants a handout.
The richest country on Earth
should have a political system
that sees the dire situation
we're in.
3,000 dead in a day.
100,000 hospitalized.
Millions facing eviction,
unemployment, and hunger
and rushes to do
something about it.
Instead, here is what the leader
of the White House coronavirus
task force was talking about
yesterday as the U.S. set a new
daily record
for coronavirus deaths.
-Space itself represents
a war-fighting domain.
And we will be prepared to
defend our nation
and defend our freedom in space.
-I mean, sure, why not?
After all, we are in a place now
where going to space
and going to Applebee's are
equally dangerous.
Also, I'm sorry,
I was not aware
our freedom was threatened
in space.
What's the issue there?
Aliens using paper straws in
their spacecraft?
Are you not allowed
to say Merry Christmas
on Zorblat 7?
Maybe Pence is obsessed with
space because he has the same
level of compassion
and charisma
as a protocol droid on
a star destroyer.
I doubt he is even
a real person.
He's like the hologram
doctor on "Star Trek Voyager."
I bet if you keep your eye
on him long enough,
he'll flicker.
All we have to do to make sure
Pence never becomes President
is press the red button
on his back.
Not to be confused with his blue
eject shame button that has
already been pressed
multiple times.
Also, what is it with
presidential administrations
using space as a topic changer?
There's a war in Vietnam
and we must pass the ERA,
shh, okay, ladies, hippies,
I hear you.
But look, look at that,
there's a guy on the moon.
His name is Neil.
Wait, shouldn't Buzz
have gone first?
It's just such
a better space name.
That's for another time.
But maybe that's their
COVID plan.
Quarantine everyone in space.
We'll be launching people into
orbit to keep the coronavirus
from spreading.
And Rudy, please,
keep your helmet on.
When I cough in the helmet,
the spit comes right back at me.
Oh, no, my teeth are
floating away again.
Although, to be honest,
I wish Trump had been talking
about space and maybe,
you know, going there,
instead he spent his entire day
as thousands of Americans were
dying alone in overwhelmed
hospitals scream tweeting
unhinged nonsense
about the election he lost.
Trying to get the result
overturned and of course,
watching Fox News.
-President Trump who attacked
Hunter Biden and his overseas
interests nearly every day
during the campaign,
tonight, tweeted a quote from
a guest on Tucker Carlson's
Fox News show.
"'10% of voters would have
changed their vote if they
knew about Hunter Biden.'"
Trump added,
"But I won anyway!"
-Good thing you included
Tucker's handle,
or he might not have seen it.
The president spent his night
tweeting at
his favorite TV personalities
like a lunatic fan boy.
Tweeting at
"Dancing with the Stars,"
"You never gave Carol Baskin
a chance! @dancingabc."
And not to be petty, but it's
worth pointing out, once again,
that our President's twitter
handle is @realDonaldTrump.
The kind of clarification porn
stars have to make.
Are we really surprised he
didn't order enough vaccines
when he couldn't even get
@donaldtrump?
Also, I'm not sure I'd tweet
anything Tucker says as fact,
since Fox News lawyers
successfully argued in court
that they shouldn't be held
liable for what he says,
because viewers should know
he is not telling the truth.
A judge actually ruled in court
that the general tenor
of the show should inform
a viewer that Carlson is not
stating actual facts about
the topics he discusses
"and instead engaging
in exaggeration
"and non-literal commentary.
given Mr. Carlson's reputation,
any reasonable viewer arrives
with an appropriate amount of
skepticism,
about the statements he makes.
And we forget the tenor of
the show, the general tenor
of Tucker Carlson's voice should
make you wonder if
he is one of the rich kids
Al Pacino yells at
in "Scent of a Woman," you know,
that scene in the end where
there's a disciplinary hearing
in a theater for some reason
and Al Pacino is just allowed
an expletive-filled
15-minute monologue which
makes the school
change its mind, I guess?
And again, for anybody who
doesn't think we're gonna have
anything to talk about
post-Trump,
that's not the only '90s movie
with third act problems.
Tucker would be a kid that
invites on student aid
to come with him to a ski trip
to stow and then add,
oh, wait, you probably can't
afford that, bro.
And I will say, I love
all the euphemisms for lies.
But my favorite is
"non-literal commentary."
Try that some time
with your spouse
after getting back from
a trip to Vegas.
I thought you said
no strip clubs.
You said that you were
going just see Jersey Goys.
Don't be ridiculous, no one
would see Jersey Goys.
That was non-literal commentary.
And on top of that, they expect
any "reasonable viewer"
to know this.
Sadly, Trump is not
a reasonable viewer.
He's the kind of guy who would
channel surf past
"Independence Day" on TNT
and think aliens
were attacking the White House.
Trump and his allies and right
wing media are all in on
creating a false mythology
around his election loss,
an unhinged fantasy world where
he actually won and votes for
anyone else are illegitimate.
And their basis for this belief
is not any proof of voter fraud,
since there is none.
They just take it as an article
of faith that there's
no way Trump could have lost.
And that's not just
a dumb cable news argument.
That's actually what their
lawsuit says.
Remember,
they've argued in court
that they are not
alleging fraud.
They have literally said,
this is not a fraud case,
because they don't have proof
of fraud.
So they have been reduced to
arguing in court filings
that it's somehow statistically
impossible that Joe Biden
could have won
the states he won.
-That document that you have
before you, that case,
the Texas v Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania,
this is the single most
important document
of the 2020 election.
I would encourage everyone to
read this document.
It is big.
For President Trump to be ahead
as far as he was at
3:00 A.M. in
these four states --
Michigan, Pennsylvania,
Wisconsin, Georgia,
and for the vote to swing by as
much as it did,
the probability of that
in one state
is one in one quadrillion.
That's one, comma, 15 zeroes.
-And 15 zeros, are you talking
about the election
or Trump's legal team?
Booyah, come on, Kayleigh,
you can't toss me
an alley-oop like that.
Actually, I'm just kidding,
Trump could never get 15 lawyers
to work for him, in fact,
and this is true,
the statement Trump issued
joining with the Texas lawsuit
was so embarrassing he could
only get one lawyer to sign it.
A guy named John Eastman,
a discredited racist who pushed
the preposterous lie
that Vice President-Elect
Kamala Harris wasn't eligible.
You can see the evolution
of the modern GOP
in a straight line
from birtherism to this.
All their insane conspiracy
theories are coming together in
the final episode.
If this were "Twin Peaks,"
and it might be,
the audience would be saying,
oh, Trump killed Laura Palmer,
but it was because he was
possessed by the spirit of Bob
aka Steve Bannon.
Huh, well, that is unsatisfying
and still,
there's been a tragedy.
And just to give you an idea of
how flimsy and error-prone
this latest court filing is,
to support their claim that it's
somehow statistically impossible
that Trump could lose,
his attorney made a claim
Trump tweeted out earlier
in the day,
writing, "President Trump won
both Florida and Ohio,
"no candidate in history,
Republican or Democrat
has ever lost the election after
winning both states."
Which is true, if you just start
counting after 1960 because in
1960, that exact thing happened.
Richard Nixon won Florida
and Ohio and lost to JFK,
do these guys do like any
research before
they write this stuff?
Can you not afford a siri
or a clippy?
Just swallow your pride
and Ask Jeeves for God's sakes.
These lawsuits have been so
nonsensical and unhinged that
even Republican judges
and judges appointed by
Trump himself has rejected them.
In one case, a Trump appointed
judge joined by two
other Republican judges
appointed by George W. Bush
wrote that "calling an election
unfair does not make it so.
"Charges require allegations
and then proof.
We have neither here."
They're basically explaining
how a court case is
supposed to work.
Normally, lawyers wear ties
and have pens and notebooks
and briefcases full of
papers that are not, you know,
leaking from the head like
an overloaded hefty bag,
and yet, Republicans
in 17 states joined
the insane Texas lawsuit seeking
to overturn millions of votes.
The two GOP Senators in Georgia
voiced their support for it
effectively saying
the Supreme Court should
overturn the will of their own
constituents.
This is what Trump
and the Republican Party
obsessively have focused on,
as thousands of America die
every day from a pandemic
they clearly don't care about.
As I said before, at some point,
you just run out of words.
All you can really is...
-That's crap, that's wrong.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over two million
meals a year to men, women,
and children living with
HIV/AIDS, cancer, and other
serious illnesses.
And they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask, we love you.